[Music]
hello and welcome to a special episode
of spectator TV I'm Natasha fos The
Spectators broadcast producer and today
we're going to be talking about rushy
Sak's first major reshuffle I'm joined
with Katie BS and frasa Nelson uh Katie
has it finished yet is it still going
we're still in the process in the sense
this is a wide reshuffle so we've had
obviously the morning as we discussed on
the first podcast the headline
announcements of suel brav and Sack
David cin brought in James cleverly the
new Home Secretary and we've now had
most of the cabinet appointments but
we're still going to be getting Junior
ranks going through in that sense I
think in terms of probably the most head
and grabbing news it does go back to how
the day began I don't think and is quite
competed with that but you do have a few
cabinet departures terz coffee she has
left the cabinet that Steve Barkley has
been demoted from Health secretary to
environment secretary and then you have
uh Rich's attempts to refresh his
cabinet with new faces even though he
has quite an old face in it now uh and
David Cameron so Victoria Atkins is the
new health secretary 2017 intake and
then Laura Trot is the chief Secretary
of the Treasury 2019 intake a former
adviser to David Cameron um so a theme
there and then Richard Holden is um
ultimately in a new role too as party
chairman and Fraser in terms of the
style of this reshuffle this hasn't been
your usual way that a prime minister
might go about it has it no this is um
completely bizarre I mean when it
started this morning um Katy called me
up quite early and I was expecting it to
be the same way that CL coutino was made
Energy Secretary I thought that was a
great chance to show somebody really
talented fresh blood that the the
government was as he said at the
conference going to St Define itself
against the failed consensus of the last
30 30 years that was his phrase a phrase
which lumped together deliberately
lumped together Cameron and Blair uh so
you think well this is the CET
commission then he's going to draw a
line here um they may have all been
Tories but I'm a different sort of
conservative so who then does he get for
this first and probably last reshuffle
he gets David Cameron the man whose hs2
policy he overturned the um and a guy
whose own foreign policy record wasn't
exactly a gleaming success um but more
to the point it doesn't seem to be any
of the 350 Tor MP suitable for the post
of foreign secretary now given that this
party has been in power for 14 years you
think they could have just one person
who' been elected who was good for that
job and David Cameron wasn't even in the
House of Lords he had to get the king to
put him in the House of Lords uh so it
is such a strange departure for our
democracy and normally the deal is that
you you choose the the team that the
voters give you I mean sure you can
appoint somebody rarely you might get a
special sort of if there's a if there's
a um emergency for example in Asylum
then you might be able to get somebody
who can handle the Ukrainian refugees
that's what happened recently but when
it comes to foreign secretary this would
be about the face you want to show to
the world now the face is now on the
four gr offices of State not a single
woman uh we've got three PPE graduates
um sunak and Jeremy Hunt and David
Cameron we've got from the schools of
Winchester Charter House and Eaton there
is something kind of quite old school
about this but the problem for a prime
minister wishing to refresh his
government is that bringing back
somebody as wellknown as David Cameron
doesn't say refresh it says rewind and I
think the impression a lot of Voters are
going to get right now is of a
conservative party which is out of ideas
and out of personnel and that's why it's
not even bringing back all the MPS it's
and bringing back people who've retired
putting them in the House of Lords and
let the other issue of how earthy is
Parliament going to hold to account a
foreign secretary who can't um set foot
in the House of Commons because he's a
lord yeah sorry yeah I think if you look
at in terms of I suppose the arguments
for David Cameron um the argument being
made by those who support that decision
is they think well this is an
experienced politician
serious politicians serious times you
think about what's happening in the
world and he will have clout when it
comes to speaking to other foreign
leaders um and you know counterparts
they also I think uh you know I think as
phas has just said and I said I've said
many times today it doesn't seem to be
consistent with the change message from
Tory conference and that 30 year moment
um but the counter that has been made to
me since then is actually um well one of
the problems they said is not so much
with individuals and you thought about
the past 30 years one of the problems is
more just the way decision- making and
governing has happened so actually
rewarding people who have lots of
experience is a good thing to do now
those are something thatly made for
David Cameron I think in terms of where
the Tory party
is there are lots of mpes who are very
happy to see David Cameron return I was
walking around Parliament being stopped
being like there's a grownup back he
would have thought would got a sensible
member around the cabinet table but they
all tend to be figures who either served
in a Cameron government or on the one
nation wing and so therefore I think by
having a situation whereby uh he sacks
bravman which I think you could have
said was about a challenge to richy
snack's Authority but combining that
bringing David Cameron back it's the
right of the party who I see the most
glum today and it's the one nation Tores
who are reading it as a win for their
faction they're part of the party and
for example tonight you have the new
conservatives meeting and that is the uh
intake of 2019 MPS quite a few of them
are in that group and they tend to be in
red wall seats no not all of them and
they have a weekly meeting so I think we
can get a bit too excited in some ways
and say oh this is all about trying to
bring down Rishi but I think it's
certainly the case this group will um
and the ones I was sping to are a bit
concerned by some of the direction in
this reshuffle and the idea is moving
away I think from some of the 2019
messaging and Katie could you talk a
little bit about what it might look like
having David Cameron as the foreign
secretary but being based in the Lords
yes so now as a result of this
appointment David C joins the Lords so
obviously lots of MPS are asking was
there really not a single Tory MP who
could have done this role run adding to
the House of Lords um but it means if
you have Min of Lords they will address
the house of laws and therefore it would
not be the foreign secretary addressing
the House of Commons now and instead it
would be the most senior Minister senior
lead now because the junior ranks are
still to be reshuffled we don't know
exactly who that could be but for
example it could be someone like Andrew
Mitchell who would then be the stand in
for any statements David Cameron gives
in the House of Lords that person would
give in the House of Commons the speaker
Lindsey Hy has voiced some concern over
the arrangement is that he's looking at
precedent and if there was a way given
how serious Foreign Affairs are whether
it's a war in Ukraine what's happening
in the Middle East um I think the
suggestion from the speaker is it's a
really unideal situation to have it so
your foreign secretary cannot face
scrutiny in all these questions um so I
think they're looking at whether there
are some ways to perhaps not have David
Cameron in the House of Commons what
they can do to improve the options for
scrutiny David Frost was um a member of
Lords who was last in government and he
earlier on um just put out um as a
statement saying that he found this was
a pretty bad situation because the Lords
fundamentally isn't political if you're
if you're a member of a lord you can get
scrutinized by other Lords but these are
guys who weren't really holding you to
to account in the same way that the
House of Commons does now you can argue
that the foreign secretary isn't really
the he's basically a mascot and Sweden
had in car built a former prime minister
who was given that role um you could say
that um that the the US had a John KY
who was a state Secretary that he was a
sort of you know a former presidential
candidate set out to be an ambassador
you could also look around the world and
say look there's now there's a market
for the Tony blers of this world the the
Bill Clinton there sort of freelance
Statesman anyway so um let's see if we
can take advantage of this and put
Cameron in that role and I think he will
be able to do that part of the job um
pretty well it's also quite possible
that we don't actually see or hear from
him that much we tend to see pictures of
a foreign secretary but seldom see tend
to see them in action so perhaps on a
day-to-day basis it wouldn't really make
that much difference but we might see
David Cameron popping up on the sofas
now and Sunday mornings to to give the
interviews or perhaps trying to defend
the government although obviously given
that he disagrees fundamentally with
brexit the country's main foreign policy
he disagrees fundamentally with decision
to reverse hs2 sinx Flagship policy he
might have um a bit of um verbal
gymnastics to perform if he wants to
come across as being fully supportive of
his predecessor um but I'm told that um
he's got an answer ready if he n he's
asked has he changed his mind about
brexit then he might have an interesting
response I'm not quite sure we're going
to get a damine conversion from him
thinking yes I should have voted um to
leave all of his time but one of the
most important jobs of a foreign
secretary is how to persuade the many
diplomats that working for you how to
sell brexit to the outside world once
when Boris Johnson was foreign secretary
he invited me into the foreign office to
speak to diplomats because he was saying
it was so difficult to find somebody who
was supportive of brexit or could see
the advantages but it was really quite
difficult to tell the diplomats um how
where were the upsides now I wasn't sure
I was particularly the best qualified
person to do that but it was a real
problem in a foreign office that was
fundamentally against brexit now can
David Cameron be the person to turn that
around that will be quite a challenge
for him but then again we are talking
about a government with um probably 12
months to the next election um and you
can see you can absolutely see why
Cameron was used but you can also see
why if you're C stor you're rubbing your
hands now thinking but this is all the
proof you need that an exhausted
conservative party has nothing more to
give and uh lastly Katie I think lots of
people are talking about the fact that
there's been so much turnover with
ministers for so many years now
obviously we've had Boris Johnson and
then Liz truss as well um do you think
that it was wise for rishy sunak to go
for such a dramatic reshuffle and and
and changed so many so many of his
cabinet in the lead up to a general
election well ultimately one of the
problems Richie Su has is if you look at
for example the King speech last week
lot of people said well it's not going
to move the dial you know this isn't
going to change anything and therefore
you continue with the status quo of your
you know the same direction your
government's going in how that might be
all very well if it's just a couple of
points between the two parties um but
you need to do something now he has done
something I don't think it's going to
mess change the polls but he clearly
thinks he going to get there so I think
he's probably in a bit of a lose lose I
think there are some moves such as you
know changing housing Minister again so
it's now been a crazy number of housing
Minister 16th housing Minister since
2010 out of time and labor are really
going on the attack on housing with
their plans to break up you know shake
up planning reform um and I think the
Tores are quite vulnerable there so I
think doing that does give the
opposition something really easy to say
which is you know you don't you don't
take this issue very seriously look how
much churn you've had that's said I
think Lee Rowley who was taken over the
brief is someone who does really want to
build houses so but how much can you
really do in that time so I think there
were I think Rich did need to have a
reshuffle because there were also quite
a lot of ministers which we haven't
really spoken about on this podcast but
there are quite a lot of ministers who
have wanted to step down so they can
focus on their seats um focus on trying
to keep their seat and really be a
constituency MP between now and the next
election um so he did need to clean
things up
but I think speaking to MPS there is a
sense that he should have done this
before the summer when there was more
time to get to know your brief and then
do things whereas now you know this
government is really running short of
time and I think therefore it's the
question as to how much really um
they're going to be achieving and if
it's more about signaling things ahead
of the election there's two things which
they really want to happen on Wednesday
one is the inflation data the number 10
wants to see a significant decrease in
inflation and the markets do expect that
you ever everything thing is the Rwanda
decision from the Supreme Court it could
well be that they get a green light for
takeoff for the Rwanda deportations if
so then this this flight should be
leaving in a few weeks time and that
could create a helpful fuss for Russ
because it we deeply controversial but
most of the public are on his side on
this but if the inflation figures
disappoint or if the Supreme Court um is
inconclusive it might say for example
you need a treaty so you has to go to
negotiate treat with Rwanda or they
simply might say no we don't think this
flies then he will be back to square one
casy wrote in her political column um
and the current issue of the magazine
that the only other thing they've got to
do is the is the mini budget um two
fateful words now but L trust made her
so dramatic but that's coming later on
this month but even that isn't suspected
to move the dial I'm not sure that
Cameron's return or the reshuffle will
move the dial but if inflation really
does start to fall quickly
and given the money supply figures
there's a good chance that we'll do or
if um the Rwanda policy goes the
government's way that might be um Sun's
hope but then again if he's 20 points
behind in the pools he's got so much and
they they want it ideally to be 10
points behind by Christmas right now I
think they'll be very lucky to be 15
points behind by Christmas and at this
rate you really struggle to see how in
Earth that they can plot the way to
Victory ktie and Fraser thanks for
joining
[Music]
us